ma c'è prezzo senza nome non blacks
[Musica]
guardate dove siamo
allora noi diciamo dove stiamo vediamo
se riconoscete il mondo dove siamo ecco
qui playtime
però l'azzurro blog si rifugia ancora
troppo bello però è un po diverso questo
gioco praticamente cosa dobbiamo fare
dobbiamo trovare tutti gli oggetti che
qua chiama un ok grafica se clicchiamo
su morse possiamo vedere tutti gli
oggetti che dobbiamo trovare i
personaggi ad esempio c'è ma milan
blacks con due teste
importante poi questa che cosa è mamino
blacks nonna granny longue
l'essere bambino un break su babbo
natale ma
comunque dobbiamo trovare più oggetti
che oggi possibile chi ne trova di più
ovviamente vincere gli amici tutta
europa di poppi priorità ed due chili di
troppo vincerà anita o vincerà vita
mettetevi comodi prende di pop corn e
lasciato un bel mi piace iniziamo la
nostra attuale
ok progrediamo ma
chi è quello che cos'è e tipo ma meno un
flex però in a ho capito di azione il
ciro sole così per iniziare bene cosi
sono appunto colore guarda
stranissimo va bene quali io voglio
andare a collezionare tutti gli oggetti
perché avevano la pelle di evitare le
gamestation ne siamo qua
dove
si sa che cosa non lo so questo che
abbiamo appena preso il nostro primo
gene perché lo trovo ma io sì infatti
grazie evitare però trovato anche questo
ma milo blacks un vecchio
che il g20 l'inglese
laggiù
ma io ti faccio saltare ma due volte
ma ho capito perché guarda come nel
gioco bisogna fare qui bravi
comunque
allora spazio che un po pagato
ben capito come funziona ok ma va bene
forse ho capito ci vuole ci vuole un
corso speciale per saltare almeno c'è
qualcosa di che cosa è successo c'è un
grosso
percorrendo
totali sbrigati di eliot al creatore sì
attento sta arrivando la di guardie 8 io
sto trovando un sacco di cose nello
statuto
evitare altre moto più genti di meno è
piccola vediamo i mangimi infatti una
cosa strana
ho trovato mobile blacks che che
sembravamo ngas estate
adesso poi di oggetti strani ma un po
confuso
ho messo il mangime ai pesci e ora breve
bensì come faccio a mettere il mangime
dove mi trovo prima devi prendere qua
questo qualche oggetto un oggetto che
c'è qua sopra è che ormai pesci bene qua
abbiamo preso tutto procediamo per voi
abbiamo assolutamente prendere
tantissimi oggetti con esito ma poi è
bellissimo esplorare questo modo a
vedere con ordine a un bel personaggio
il girasole che non mi ricordo come si
chiama voi forse lo sapete
ok c'è un'altra porta ad ambrì e qua qua
c'è anche un ascensore maratona a primo
anno
si sta passando millepiedi mai un altro
personaggio non è il canale vedi essere
un buono possiamo bastare ci serve
qualcosa per passare quindi ok pratica
ma guardano giace all'oggetto bellissimo
così è un cagnolino il cagnolino però
come facciamo prendere lui probabilmente
vediamo
maria
io so
much ha preso 60 rom o meno blacks
eccola è già riuscita tenta così non è
stato
tenete brutta o un cane per superare
la prima trovare la strada in modo di
farla si no tu cosa vi aiuto io dovevo
può bastare devi andare tutti destra
sinistra mi ha mangiato
qua non può prendervi la stessa mia vita
ho visto
ma di un ingiusto perché proprio a me
fatemi passare perfetto io derivi dai
toni
è quasi un oggetto la testa non la
minogue le
aveva rubato player qui raccolsi abbiamo
collezione sono un cittadino mi non mex
poche imprese anch'io e diamo di noi non
c'è più niente dobbiamo tornare indietro
dopo che ci aspetta li guarda non so se
sia una via d'uscita qua
no al mese gara dall urlo tiro di nuovo
se un piccolo seco dovevamo prendere la
testa di mala giunge aiuto sì mi sa che
abbiamo già preso quello che dovevamo
prendere qua quindi tanto vale ora
tornare indietro lo sto continuando ad
esplorare ma che ritrovo cosa sei sono
tornato indietro e rame è spezzato me ne
so niente
come faremo passare proviamo a mettere
la mano a roma milan blacks
svitiamo di assicurare o testi
come fatto
[Musica]
mai fatto niente ma momento però
sorpassare con pelle veramente
no
sono riuscito a passare ma mi ha preso
il bruco magnetico o no allora se
diventi ma milon blacks innanzitutto 96
finito e non so perché mi ha fatto
ricominciare daccapo vabbè il gusto
questa diventi bambino blacks riesci a
passare guarda questo arrivando un
attimo per ora devo stare attenta a non
farmi prendere dal progetto ok partiamo
dalle tre mete
domani mi hai fatto a diventare un
bambino blacks allora se ti vuoi
trasformare il miur premere mi morse ok
poi selezionare quello che vuoi diventa
ecco sono quattro bambini
adesso che facciamo saltare il tempo di
nazione sono amici papera lento qua però
perché ti prende il brutto ma domani non
blacks posso mangiare lui il bruco no e
allora come ti mangia deve essere un
paziente poi passare quando non passa
mai che fai mi ha spinto solo non ce la
fa cup il sito bastare perché sono
troppo compatta che
provo passare adesso
ce l'ho fatta che ora devo assolutamente
scappati esco prendere l'accesso a
stagione che aspetta pieno costretto
altro e poi capillare femmina perché
c'era anche il mas che ti ricordi è sì
allora se clicchiamo su aggiornamenti
ok
ora diventò il bruco
allora io provo diventare mobil home
blacks ok e provo ad affrontarla al
nuovo devo prima di prenderla stesso ci
ha preso prima e vabbè e maura pietra di
testo perché se il bambino blacks so di
mangiare la stessa
emozione di guardavano milan blacks naja
credo che abbiamo finito fare la
gamestation che dobbiamo andare nelle
altre stesse scriviamo un'altra area ok
sto tornando indietro incidente del
treno il treno ha smesso di funzionare a
220 fase di riparazione da parte degli
ingegneri atti come nel giorno chiave
ci servirà qualcosa o baby nobile con le
droghe come sono troppi c'è scritto che
baby long legged è la sorella di mami
long l'ex ora voglio diventare baby
blacks provvedere come ripreso l'uomo si
e guardate che io qua su un altro tema
di moretti si è trasformato in qualcosa
guarda non è carinissima con queste
codine sì sì
allora andiamo in musical memory si può
l'idea vediamo un po come ho trovato
un'altra chiave verde no hanno scuse un
microfono
music hall memory ok era molto difficile
nel gioco reale questa parte si per
fortuna non è uguale questo la prima
versione della mente inizia il gameplay
in cui giochiamo musical memory non
permette difficile è stato quello con il
cane paga film
pensato di tempo
non riesce allora io sono normale ho
trovato un voto 6 a
chi devi tagliare il pollo so però
pensavo di trovarci qui invece
mi aspetto ma io non ti vedo forse un
altro posto mano rossa
socio fanno un sacco di cose qua sotto
bene dopo mi dirai dove si perché
praticamente ho trovato una specie di
fabbrica dove fanno i giocattoli cento
stiamo nella fabbrica di danaro
sanità
ma qui c'è qualcosa di draghi è un
codice da mettere mano l'idea di polizia
la metro a caso e poi c'è scritto cosa e
chi è scritto rosso arancio nel 2o
mancione due ci sono 129 con
combinazioni quindi non indovinare
capito io sto andando in giro dietro
questi la binetti ma non lo so spero di
trovare la meta un area dove ho trovato
caso vaso boni
preferito evitare è solo nel music
almeno di quello dove ci sono i bottoni
è meglio che non vai tu da solo perché
sennò ti perdi circo corto coralità
allora dobbiamo provare ad aprire la
porta qui risolvendo queste
questo nome idea mettiamo vero
che questo come d'oriente ho preso bar
di babylon let alti che cosa sta
succedendo poche virtù eco vitale come
un fattore non lo so né cure dopo i suoi
labirinti tra gli ostacoli sono verso il
18 ott vediamo qua non si può entrare
sì c'è un posto c'è segreto laportablu
risolve questa domanda cos'è un nuovo e
più piace ecco che evitare si ferma
invece vista parlare di sé nuovi bene si
fa distrarre
io continuo questo o no ne uscivo duro
ma questo tipo baldi infatti devi per
forza mettere una risposta di hicks da
tempo io ho preso teddy long l'ex zombie
hai preso poco preso quasi
sempre di ma allora noi fatto tu provi
un'altra delle morti che ho preso
vediamo baldi
logora
dove sei tu sei già fermo lo sto facendo
il codice qui è impossibile dal non me
lo ricordo
ok ragazzi abbiamo guardato online
perché voglio forniamo un male era ed è
vediamo all'inizio verde rota giallo e
rosso
rosso verde rosa no non funziona ma
allora se non troviamo
guarda questo momento qual è stata
principale vi ricordate essi vi
ricordate questa charlie come si possono
nessuno cile allora provo a trasformarli
vediamo un bravo amiamo
a salire allora divenne diventino
gremito blacks non sono diventato di
gruppo
io pure loro
costretto c'è scritto ferro oppure il
bastone della vecchiaia guardato
qualche oggetto nascosto sicuramente
quadrati coppa star qua sotto sì sì
sotto il passato di non mi fa passare
perché doveva passare è
grande wow sono in un'area in cui non
sono mai stata parte dove ti sei perso
tu prima si è fatto
ho preso l'oggetto una chiave ok
torniamo dove evitare prima che si perda
si aiutato mi sono trovato trasformato
nel del coniglio
perché lì ho trovato ha morso di bozzo
io non l'ho trovata lì andiamo adesso
qui e ho visto che non si può fare più
niente di sicuro bonuccelli ci sono ma
la formica rossa risposto vediamo in
grado di con il corpo di
pavia del nostro paese vediamo adesso
diamo di qua al alagi banche sono questo
io e poi vediamo qualcosa perchè un pò
all'inizio nato ho preso qualcosa
dovevo dire in questa povera troviamo
prima qua cos'è di grappa
di gran parte successo mettere
trasportato da qualche parte ho trovato
un punk un pilastro
non lo so cos'è oggi premiamo di tutti
infatti a pillar però con lo skate
però proprio trovato qualcosa qui
aspetta aspetta una scala verte sulla
scala conosca
mi aspetto di vedere
no non so niente
ho trovati qua
inventario completo
ecco
ho preso un omino blacks su
che cosa
in speciale prima mirror l'ex preso
anch'io ho trovato bambino un ex
football
basta peso solo ridotto peso di io
ok
ma chi è questo un personaggio con l'asp
in poi trovato moby non l'ex astronauta
non voglio anch'io
eccola qui all'angolo ma riprendiamo la
trovi proprio qui all'angolo giovedì
era nascosta bene allora stiamo per
avvicinarsi avvicina di nuovo corridoio
se il corridoio di bambino modalità che
esistano le sue braccia all'induzione
nobili crediamo ma non professionali ok
c'è il braccio di mobile me è
la più breve presa famila un blitz
distrutto ok lo so che cos'è questo
orologio gigante che succede per esempio
la notizia come dire al mio braccio
sicuramente serve a qualcosa lo vediamo
forse per trovare le altre steam dice
beh non
capisco perciò la mia va beh qui abbiamo
preso tutto e oggi questa ci manca da
esplorare scriveteci nei commenti qual è
il vostro personaggio preferito di pop
hybrid i'm il mino sono indecisa tra chi
si misti e poppi la bambola mi piace
euro anno il blocchetto invece piace pgp
paga pilla esatto ma anche un
orsacchiotto quello di ben
possiamo ti faccia ancora un'altra porta
che non abbiamo esplorato 4
nel mondo waka saghe
carino
novellino stato trovato qualcosa qui
dice il braccio c'è il volpino
proviamolo subito dice che ho già questo
questo oggetto che carini romana sul
vampiro di zone non c'entra niente
wyplay
quindi statue questo qui non l'abbiamo
fatto
mi ricordi non è vero questo è quello
che va capillare salto aspetta in
tributo in questa partita
la testa incastrata nella porta dobbiamo
trovare tutto perché inserisci il disco
musicale aspetta io il disco musicale ce
l'hai si brucia di scommetti ho vinto ma
mancando mammina un blacks avventura mi
metto momento dove microg alessi cece
verbale sono sceso giù controllo potrò
caccia
io ho trovato un pallone ha detto calcio
per fare gol
ho preso il palo aspettano
non toccare il mio pallone ho fatto da
un abito bambino black scalzone
mi sa che qualcuno sarà che un morso
dell'altro è eco in qualcuno e premio
vitale disastro ma magari in vantaggio
non lo so però proviamo a fare gol
se l'è fatta
ho trovato una scorciatoia qui
proviamo a salire
ecco sono salito guarda la vedi che qui
c'è una porta a porta no no è un oggetto
che si può prendere
bravissimo come deve trovarli tutti
perché io sinceramente però
interessa ma minorile netflix
bravo e non avrei mai trovata bisogna
stare superattenti io che via via si ma
vi ricordate questo corridoio dove c'è
la dove bisognava spingere il carrellino
ecco i giochi e nero è un po un
labirinto
42 milanese giocatore
se
uno non è cattiva lei mi trasformo in
che sinistra adesso perché la adoro
questo dire questo personaggio tutto
verde sei contento perché sono questi
mesi dovete
posiziona mela a ma non ce l'ha bruciato
è deciso di rimanere mobil home black
sea buongiorno le no ma che vince e sa
trarre tevere che mi faccio la chiamo
bianca qui ma mi non blacks scheletro
richiamo non era una chiave bianca è uno
choc ei fra tantissima troviamo la mii
amo ad hai trovato bisogno ti trasformi
mai allora dov'è miccoli mamma mia che i
suoi siamo il primato effettivamente non
riesco a trovare le porte upa allora se
segui me che tu probabilmente ti perdi
ok in realtà sta seguendo un altro
giocatore perché veramente più bravo
dinho in nero guarda che io mi ricordo
benissimo dove andare
allora è questo labirinto sembra bagato
proviamo segui mio ok a aiuto che paura
che brutta quella film da pagliaccio ho
trovato qualcosa qui guarda che cosa
pieno caramella presa
prima kenya ben ritorna normale però che
si porta poco
non sappiamo e lunghi natura
bambino bressan
si parte per me una terza prova ve la
ricordate che io ho trovato bambino
blacks cavernicola
freghiamo
vabbè io divento bambino blacks
astronauta
mattia linee mantiene in equilibrio
forse un altro bambino blacks versione
vacanza al mare c'è una bellissima lo
voglio io mi sono sposato ma bisogna noi
difficilissima
tornate attenti a non cadere
vediamo chi arriva la prima vice
italiani quale arrivò primo perché è
troppo bravo
speriamo che cosa speriamo che vitale
cava no non lo so però cambiata ma come
si fa a l'ultimo impossibile da superare
e hai lasciato mi piace ma sotto subito
un big per portarmi fortuna e poter
vivere altrimenti dice la vita ti
ammazzo io mi sto sempre parlando sempre
che bisogna prendere un po di rincorsa
oppure bisogna trasformarsi io provo a
trasformarmi in marmi long letto io
saluto ciao ho
detto quindi se quando si passa prova a
diventare la testa gigante di mamme la
collezione di un'idea vediamo
si no non ha funzionato
allora io divento paga film
giusto con lo skate da
vinci
bene allora io non credo che non si può
passare sei riuscito a passare ma per
che cosa sta succedendo aiuta mi
ha buttato fuori
che i ragazzi purtroppo il gioco non lo
so disconnesso comunque abbondiamo
quanto estino abbiamo preso è se abbiamo
vinto 3 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19
20 21
4 25 le micro 25 massimilaino 24
bene fai tu
giusto se volete continuo ha lasciato un
bel mi piace ora vi lasciamo
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quello che preferite buona
visione ciao ciao